hello fellow geeks abita here bringing
you another fantastic video for all your
rog fans and newcomers alike
many fans of the rog gaming series can't
wait for what's to come later this year
in 2020
with that we bring you the gig's guide
to the rog gaming laptop series 2020
edition
work and play has never been so easy
until now
capable of both graphic intensive gaming
and professional level content creation
these two laptops will give you the best
of both worlds
starting with the rog zephyrus duo 15.
this futuristic looking based upper
machine not only spots the best gaming
laptop performance but also boasts a
secondary screen
it's the first of its kind to feature a
built-in rod screen pad plus display
designed to be tilted up to 13 degrees
for a more comfortable viewing
[Music]
it can deepen gamer's immersion with
games optimized for the multi-screen
experience
aaa games like dying light 2 will
enhance your view by moving mission
objectives inventory and more to the
second screen
it also helps to keep additional windows
such as chat and stream controls on deck
while gaming on the main screen
plus you get to enjoy a larger working
area for your creative projects with a
screen space
it is equipped with the latest tension
intel core i9 cpu and nvidia geforce rtx
2080 super gpu
to help keep the laptop cool the
zephyrus 2015 relies on a new active
aerodynamic plus system that draws in
cooler air and reduces noise
combined with the liquid metal thermal
compound on the cpu this machine
supports incredible performance while
dissipating heat more efficiently and
with lesser noise users can not only
switch between ultra fast 300hz screen
for competitive play
but also for pro level content creation
with its pantone validated display
to accompany the immersive visuals you
can enjoy crystal clear high-res audio
delivered by the ess saber hi-fi dac and
enjoy rich audio with a 7.1 channel
virtual surround sound
at just 20.9 millimeters thick and
weighing only 2.4 kilograms the laptop
comes in a magnesium illuminated chassis
that is both strong and durable
it is also packed with a high capacity
90 watt hour battery
perfect for long gaming sessions on the
go gamers can inspect a lot of street
cred and bragging rights owning this bad
boy
next up is the rog zephyrus s15
this 15.6 inch laptop is both powerful
and versatile
meant for anyone who wants a compact yet
powerful laptop that is able to not only
work hard but also play hard
this laptop is only 18.9 millimeters
thin and weighs under 2 kilograms
making it an ultra slim and portable
gaming machine
the fusion of the latest 10th gen intel
core i7 cpu with up to the geforce rtx
2080 super gpu takes the cake for
support performance
an ultra fast 300 hertz refresh rate
with 3 milliseconds response time
makes this laptop great for fast-paced
games and crisp graphics
100 rgb color space and pantone validate
display also make it great for creative
professionals
the zephyrus s15 also sports a new
cooling system combined with liquid
metal thermal compound on the cpu to
provide efficient performance and system
longevity
if you're a fan of esports or want to
power up the best of what the esports
arena can offer say no more than rog
strixscar 15.
as the fourth iteration of the esports
focus strict scar series of gaming
laptops this year's models provides all
that game is praised it's pretty
successful and improves on it further
dominate with the scars 300 huds at 3
milliseconds gaming display and with the
latest 10th gen intel core i7 processor
and geforce rtx graphics card to give
you the best performance
and if you want to go loud and show off
to your friends the streak scar comes
decked with a wraparound light bar and
illuminated backlit keys in full rgb
gamers also get more efficient cooling
with liquid metal thermal compound on
the cpu and well ventilated exterior
keeps noise levels to a minimum the
keystone is back with its second
iteration the keystone too
it offers new ways to personalize your
machine and protect your personal data
these nfc enabled keys unlock access to
personalized settings such as stored
safe profiles
lighting effects
sound effects and shadow drive a private
storage in an encrypted partition on the
ssd that remains hidden allowing only
the owner of the keystone to see it
this is a whole package for those who
wants to be at the cutting edge of
esports gaming
and finally we have the rog strix g15
and g17
if you love options that cater to your
gaming needs and budget then this is a
laptop for you you can decide on either
a 15.6 inch display or a 17.3 inch
display and a slew of more variants such
as ram gpu display and storage options
with its streamlined design the rog
strix g15 and g17 feature up to the
latest 10th gen intel i7 cpu and up to
rtx 2060.
this gives it the ability to take full
advantage of up to a blazing fast 144
hertz at 3 milliseconds display
packing familiar features of the
previous model showcased in this video
liquid metal cooling and improved
ventilation on the chassis
gamers will enjoy peace of mind with a
desktop inspired keyboard dedicated
hotkeys highlighted wasd keys and 4-zone
rgb lighting for all the rgb lovers
that said the strix 15 r17 is the best
bang for buck laptop for anyone who
takes a reliable gaming machine